diamond starci male alla fine se lo
meritava certo ti ricordi quella volta
che ho messo laica quella tiva mero suo
cugino e quella volta è uscito con gli
amici lì nascosto veramente detto
nuvoloso vabbè sentisse le hai fatte
perché lui se lo meritava comunque che
dopo una lezione così si sveglia ma
forse riguardi una macchina è stato un
po troppo fabiamo che te frega
allora impara ma adesso mi ha lasciato e
allora molte le trovi un altro tanto non
ti merita va a milano ma dove vai tutta
così scollata copri che accoglie i tagli
basta una folata di vento e chi prendi
un accidenti sookyou di chi ha così e
che di questa è la pasta al forno che
abbiamo averlo mangiato ma non importa
non vedi che sei magro devi mangiare su
ciao tesoro
quando arrivi mandare un messaggino ciao
como aiuto sono indecisa allora gli
scrivo o non li scrivo scrivi li
assolutamente dice però se li scrivo
magari pensa che sia una sotto na se non
gli scrivo rischio magari di perderlo
per sempre
infatti dovrete iscrivervi ma cosa ti
scrivo inizia con un ciao come stai
ma ciao come stai ti penso ho ciao come
stai usciamo cesa uscita pure questa con
questo pure questo non mi ricordo spa
sia monet conosciuto nello scorso il mio
compleanno ma che davvero può essere
brutta briata vabbè roba da niente va
avanti c'è suscita ammazza questo che
bono è stata veramente una notte di
passione il mio fidanzato amo mi sono
sbagliato scusate questo è praticamente
molto simile a quell'amico nostro con
questa uscita bono anche lui bono però
non no non era lui
amo dobbiamo studiare abbiamo la
verifica settimana prossima ci pensiamo
noi
e no ai no adesso spegne andiamo a
studiare
facciamo così io ti ripeto tutto
programma per 30 volte così la marino in
vari sia mo tranquilla sono in macchina
quale sto cercando parcheggio a quella
sostanza meno appena rubato uno mi vuole
nessuno diede tutto è fidanzato l'unica
è solo da una vita non ti preoccupare lo
troverà in fidanzato guarda che anche io
quando mi sono fidanzata con luca
primero come te poi è arrivato quando
meno me lo aspettavo
io già mi vedo con dieci gatti si cela
sempre e che tragica morerod allora ma
non lo dico io amo te l'ho detto che
mamma ha vinto la lotteria fortunata e
che andiamo in giro a mirko da scuola a
new york non ci portano a predappio
morosolo posizione un po sfigata
progetto di passarmi è proprio mangiare
davanti a me non tutti mangiano non
ingrassano come fa un uomo è questione
di costituzione se potessi ti giuro che
per regalerà il metabolismo mio
amo si sono ancora da quella spiegata ma
ti pare se non fosse per farmi fare i
compiti con quello non ci avrei mai
avuto niente che fare caserta taranto
ecco mangone è un cesareo ma viene fatto
i compiti che grazie proprio a te lo
merito che sarà mica per speciale che
opera
amo a chi l'hai detto a nessuno te lo
giuro
beh forse solo alla chiara però lei la
mia migliore amica ed è anche amica tua
quindi non penso che lo andrà a
raccontare in giro e poi l'ha detto che
poi forse anche a martina però mi sono
sentita così tanto in colpa che sono
corsa in chiesa per confessarmi è uno
molto uscita dalla chiesa ha incontrato
mamma e quindi e quindi hanno detto però
secondo me non l'ha presa benissimo
forse scoprire che sua figlia ha perso
la verginità la faccia un po sentire
male infatti è caduta per terra svenuta
tu sei pazza
no no non andare io ti voglio bene lo
sai che di me ti puoi fidare prima che
torni
ricordatevi di scrivervi al canale e se
questo video arriverà 100.000 like
girerò la seconda parte e racconterò so
se il ricatto a milano